it's been four months since your last
bike you may fool yourself into digging
out some frozen kelp but you know that
dinner actually sits comfortably 200
miles away it's so frustrating the last
thing you need right now is a huge male
looking for trouble
[Music]
at first glance the Arctic feels
brutally devoid of life
though a select group of animals have
figured out a way to thrive
but the real force here works quietly
underfoot every winter ci starts small
and delicate then it grows over millions
of square miles how is it possible that
this freezer holds the key to our entire
planet like hell on sea ice breathes
life into the Arctic every year in a
cycle that impacts the climate across
the globe this is the story from the
edge of the Canadian Arctic where it all
starts
my name is Bertie Gregory Roman National
Geographic wildlife filmmaker everything
is at stake we're all waiting for the
big freeze temperatures are starting to
drop in the Hudson Bay
but it needs to get a lot colder for the
saltwater to completely freeze over
until then the seals are just too far
away and the hungry bears have no choice
but to wait
[Music]
this guy is a big bruiser and he's
coming in I called the other polar bears
they're coming to the water's edge ready
for the big freeze but right now the ice
isn't quite ready and you can see him
kind of falling through and stumbling
under his weight now you spend four or
five months on land starving not eating
anything and you know that as soon as
that sea freezes that's your fast food
buffet is ready so like this bear I'd
spend a lot of time stood out on the
water's edge looking at it
[Music]
the Arctic hosts our planet's most
brutal snowstorms but today weather is
the last thing this bear needs to worry
about
there we go
they speak now on the left approaching
be even bigger Bell on the right so give
me about to get some action
[Music]
[Music]
oh they just talk to each other
[Music]
hopeful kids we've added an unnecessary
amount of dramatic music you'd be
forgiven for thinking that these two
guys are in some brutal fight to the
death but actually at this time of year
males don't really have anything to
fight over you know there's no females
in heat there's no food
and instead they've got a bit of a
bromance going and now I mean look at
them after hammering each other having a
little smooth together although they're
solitary most of the year when males
finally meet up they can be really
playful
they often pair up with a sparring buddy
because in a few months they'll be on
the ice fighting in deadly battles over
breeding rights but polar bears are
incredibly well adapted to the
challenges of these hardships they're
enormous 12 inch wide paws are like
snowshoes spreading their weight on thin
ice they're short gripping claws and
soft foot pads also prevent them from
slipping the Bears narrow head long neck
allows them to grab seals through their
breathing holes in the ice and if you
have to pull a 600-pound seal out of the
water then a massive set of canines with
set back premolars allow you to bite
down deep
but hands down their key adaptation is
their incredible sternal insulation if
we switch from a normal camera like this
camera and the camera you're looking at
me on now to a thermal camera you're now
looking at me in heat so if I take my
glove off you see how my hands and my
face a bright orange that means I'm
losing heat to the environment like
there is no tomorrow I'm so badly
adapted to this place whereas if you
look at the bear he's that dark purple
almost black color and that's because of
that thick thick fur which obviously I
don't have my biggest challenge here is
keeping warm enough whereas his is
keeping cool enough hang on Steve you
seen that bear up there he's cooking him
pretty good
hey buddy you need to start thinking
twice about walking in there are very
few animals they will actually try and
hunt people and polar bears are one of
those animals hey slow down
[Music]
we got an easy meal hey blow it out hey
slow down
[Music]
hey close up
[Music]
there you go sit down sit
there you go well Steve told it to sit
and it's at unbelievable this bear will
just have to wait for the big fries to
get his dinner along with the others all
stalling for time along the coast the
most powerful force in the Arctic starts
small really small so fragile that it
could break in your fingertips
it grows inch by inch almost when no
one's looking but once it starts there's
no stopping him
the water hits 28.8 Fahrenheit and the
big freeze has finally arrived
[Music]
finally what was thousands of miles of
liquid is turned into this rock solid
ice pathway across the ocean polar bears
have depended on the big freeze for
millennia the problem is that our
warming climate is delaying its arrival
by more than a day each year that means
that this generation has lost atleast a
month of hunting that previous ones
relied on we've got to turn this around
and save our planet's most vital cooling
system
[Music]
and off he goes slowly but surely our
bear starts his trek out over the ocean
for as long as the ice will let him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you